hey youtubers it's Charlie so earlier
this week there was this anonymous
person blasting Warner Brothers claiming
they used to work at the studio talking
specifically a lot about the Wonder
Woman movie so this is going to be
breakdown of what's going on and why
that's all bullcrap
so you may have heard that someone was
blasting Warner Brothers and saying
there was a big mess in general with all
their films behind the scenes they were
particularly singling out wonder woman
because that's like the upcoming DC
movie but from the things that it talks
about in the things that it leaves out
it sounds like this was like a
relatively low-level person like an
intern working for someone who was way
down on the totem pole because they
really don't get into specifics when
they talk about some of the problems
behind the scenes they don't even
mention geoff johns once they don't talk
about any of the things that have
changed as a result of the
dissatisfaction that people have
expressed with some of the previous DC
films this year so the only one in any
official capacity you know from the
other side of the firing line that has
said anything about this are reacted to
it is patty Jenkins the director of the
Wonder Woman movie who is like you know
who acts kinda like you woke up in the
middle of the night like wait what what
the hell is going on this is bullshit
get outta here so just to clarify what's
going on with the Wonder Woman movie and
what's going on behind the scenes at
Warner Brothers now so Wonder woman right
now is still unlike work print form like
everything that they've shot is all
crammed together in one massive edit so
it's like four and a half hours long
they have to cut it down to what will
eventually be the theatrical run that
just like a long process it takes a long
time to cut that down there'll be a
bunch of different cuts of the film as
they test it with audiences it's the
same thing with every single film in the
history of filmmaking so like a lot of
the stuff that was said about the film
being a mess doesn't really address that
it just says the film is a mess well you
know all films are messes until an
editor comes in and works their magic
and turns it into something that you or
I might go see a movie theater that
makes sense so the Wonder Woman movie i
think is gonna go a long way to address
a lot of the complaints that people who
have been dissatisfied with DC movies
whether or not you like the last couple
of DC movies wonder woman is like a
shift in tone for the film's just
because the Wonder Woman character comes
from a very different place than Batman
Batman is a very dark character Wonder
woman has a lot of dark things going on
in her life but she's kind of like this
symbol of hope so you know that's why is
very easy for them to do the film during
World War one because there's people
dying everywhere the earth has been torn
up with trench warfare just everything
is a complete mess
so she steps in to try and fix
everything so that you know you're gonna
get that general sense from the tone of
the film to have a very calming presence
on all the Angry bros so that will be
happening like a metaphorical way with
the Phantom in a literal way in the
context of the film so it feels like
this big fan letter that everyone's been
talking about is really just that it's
like a fan who was like an intern or
like a low-level grunt at warner
brothers who is dissatisfied with the
previous films and is trying to vent
their frustrations without really having
any general knowledge of what's actually
going on
so in general I would just treat this
like the crying baby on the airplane
that you're just forced to sit next to
for like the next half hour
you just like put your headphones in
just ignore it it's just complete
bullshit
so what's gonna happen in the next
couple of months is you will continue to
see new Wonder Woman trailers because
wonder woman is not coming till next
summer so there'll be plenty more
marketing in the spring to you know
typically when they get within a couple
months of a movie coming out that's when
they really start marketing films so
that's still a long ways off by that
time they'll have a much stronger cut of
the film you'll start hearing a lot more
about it as well as the other films that
will follow like justice league like
typically when studios are really afraid
of films they won't let journalists
anywhere near they want to advance
screenings they'll embargo certain types
of coverage for a film until after its
release
so just to show how confident they are
in the stuff that's coming
warner brothers had journalists to the
set of Justice League and they watched a
scene get filmed months before comic-con
happened in part of the scene that they
got to see was what ended up in that
Justice League trailer from comic-con so
i'll put a link to that at the end of
this but they're just so confident in
the stuff that they're working on that
they gave you the work print version of
the trailer like it's not super polished
like a normal trailer would be just like
here's the footage that we shot we kind
of cut this together in a really quick
way it's just a taste for what is coming
in really i think like the big purpose
of that was just to let you know what
the tone of the film is going to be the
characters are starting to feel more
like the characters that you remember
from the comics whichever you feel like
was one of the big complaints against
batman be superman was that even though
Batman felt like an amazing version of
batman superman did not feel like
Superman so it's just like a little
course correction on some of the more
hopeful characters in the DC Universe
and based on this it seems like that's
what's happened I mean obviously we
haven't seen Superman back yet because
officially they're still trying to keep
that mystery up we know what his status
is but they basically said that he's
part of the Justice League in the comics
of course he's going to come back and
justice league at some point but
hopefully that clears up
why people have been blasting warner
brothers studio because of this
anonymous letter for you know very
circumspect so I'm just treat it like
bullshit gossip you can totally dark
don't worry about it they still have a
long time before Wonder woman is actually
going to be finished before it's gonna
be the film that you will see in
theaters as well as justice like there's
still filming justice league right now
and remember that when they're editing
films there will typically be three or
four different cuts of a film at least
especially the really big films that
they'll test with different audiences
just to see how people react to certain
parts of the film like when they were
making guardians of the galaxy they said
there was even like a cut of the film
that didn't have any jokes in it if you
can imagine that like a weird cut of
guardians of the galaxy
it was supposed to be very not funny so
like if somebody saw that cut of the
film and then said oh my god guardians
of the galaxy is a complete mess
there's no jokes in it maybe it would
have any understanding of what the final
film look like which wound up being one
of the most funny Marvel films that's
been made so far so you couldn't tell
I'm very excited about wonder woman
there's gonna be another trailer but it
probably won't drop for at least another
month or two so in the meantime there is
a new round of the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video is just a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card will be a
bunch of DC bunch of Marvel next week
and they're supposed to be walking dead
preview tonight so if they talk about
anything interesting
I will totally do a walking dead video
on Monday while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
watch that Wonder woman trailer again
you can click here to watch the Justice
League trailer thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five i'll
see you guys tonight